donc vous allez incarner des agents
secrets et vous allez devoir infiltrer
une plante pour pouvoir me ramener une
mallette classé top secrète
[Musique]
le compte à rebours est lancé
cette famille à une heure pour tenter
d'accomplir sa mission et sortir de la
pièce
regardez voilà dans les po trouver un
objet un code fouillé chaque recoin de
la pièce les joueurs doivent chercher
des indices cachés et les combinés entre
eux pour pouvoir avancer deux lacets
chaque minute compte car le temps défile
à grande vitesse la clé de la réussite
le travail en équipe 684 après tu
regardes ton 4,468 géraldine le sait
bien elle a déjà expérimenté plusieurs
escape game
qu'est ce qui vous plaît vous dans ce
concept réfléchir et ses 2 voilà de
faire marcher les méninges et décrypter
les indices
j'ai un peu de mal avec les codes dès
qu'il ya un peu de matches un peu
largués mais sinon c'est sympa il porte
une casquette bleue il n'a pas
d'alliance il n'est pas blond n'a pas de
barbe
en cas de difficultés des joueurs
peuvent compter sur le maître du jeu
grâce à des caméras disposées dans
chaque pièce
benoît distille des indices pour aider
le groupe à progresser
suivant comment le groupe avance pouvoir
les indiqué de temps en temps les
aiguiller pour qu'il reparte sur les
bonnes lignes puissent quand même aller
aller jusqu'au bout des ongles
le but principal c'est qu'ils s'amusent
en famille ou entre amis le concept de
l'escape game séduit celui entre 34 et
296 et en particulier les novices moi je
connaissais pas du tout c'est vrai que
demandent notre équipe connaissait déjà
mais moi je connaissais pas du tout et
en revanche on n'était pas assez de ces
taux du cerveau quand même hein
parce que c'était quand même assez
compliqué mais franchement c'était super
vraiment sympa à faire vraiment à faire
et à refaire je crois qu'à une deuxième
salve on pourra quand cela passe je
crois donc voilà super maman extra
original immersive dynamique la folie et
ce qu'est games se propage en france ça
vous a plu s'est bien passé pour
répondre à une demande grandissante
gaëtan vient d'ouvrir deux salles siro
c'est c'est une activité en famille
c'est quelque chose sur des thèmes bien
précis vous voyez chez nous on est sur
le cluedo tout le monde et joue au
cluedo l'autre salée sur le thème de
mission impossible
tout le monde connaît et on s'imagine
dans la peau du personnage et petits et
grands c'est quelque chose qui qui plaît
beaucoup et qui fait c'est vraiment un
très très bon moment nadège a également
choisi de surfer sur la vague
il ya quelques semaines elle décide de
monter un escape game éphémère autour de
l'univers d'harry potter
visiblement si je suis votre
raisonnement une potion correspond à la
lettre elle souhaite faire connaître
cette activité le temps des vacances
scolaires nous dans l'avallonnais moi de
mon but c'était balles at war proposer
au plus près pour les gens qui peuvent
pas toujours se déplacer avec sera
valeur y avait pas ce genre d'activité
et puis pour apporter un petit peu de
nouveautés ce véritable tendance du
moment
l'escale games ne cesse de se développer
en bourgogne franche comté
la région compte désormais une vingtaine
de salles
justement